[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
well
[ __ ] him
i guess has a new meaning to it now
today
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em
i think the
fascists in this country
have underestimated
the sleeping giant that they have
woken
oh
you want mother wokers do you well you
[ __ ] woke up
the biggest giant that you'll see
we're watching now here on c-span
uh
video of the
live coverage from washington let me
pull up the sound here you can see here
people protesting outside the supreme
court we know this morning
in the decision on dobbs
[Music]
the conservative justices even though
they said they wouldn't susan collins
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
lying pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
said they would not overturn a woman's
right to her bodily autonomy
today
they stood by
their draft decision
[Music]
the protest just a tip of the iceberg
for the protest in this country
it's not just gonna stop with these
little protests here in washington
these protests are gonna move across the
country and they're gonna turn into a
coalition of voters you dumb
[ __ ]
and that's how we stop these son of a
[ __ ]
enough's enough of this goddamn [ __ ]
clarence thomas saying
that he he wants to take contraception
away same-sex marriage same-sex
relationships
when will these [ __ ] fascists in this
country wake up to the delusion that
they're supporting people against
freedom
against liberty
yesterday the supreme court showed us
that they are not for states rights
they don't want the states to have
rights
to tell you what you can and can't
regulate on guns
but this morning
oh they're all for [ __ ] states rights
all for it
when they can tell you
what you can and can't do with your body
who wouldn't who you can and can't love
who you can and can't [ __ ] because
that's what thomas said that's what he
believes
and they're not just coming for abortion
in red states
they're coming for women's bodily
autonomy across the country it won't
stop
at dobbs it won't stop it ro
it won't stop at the state's rats the
state does not have the [ __ ] right
to your body
[Music]
and to your choice
of what you and your doctor decide to do
with medical procedures
life-changing or not
life-saving or not
those are your [ __ ] liberties
and if you're not [ __ ] furious this
morning
about what is going on in our democracy
you are not doing it correctly
all these people out there that were
[ __ ] clamoring about not going into
oh i can't go into burger king
and order a whopper cause i don't have a
vaccine where's my freedom
you stupid [ __ ] these same
[ __ ] are gonna be hit in the
face when they can't even go buy a
condom
it's time
for you
the listener
to make the choice
to do your civic duty
and engage in the ballot
every way you can
it doesn't matter i'm not talking about
just marking your ballot register get
out to vote support the candidates give
money if you can now is the time and
there's only one party that is not
fascist
only one of them
that has decided that democracy
is the way to equality and equity and
the way to deliver liberty through
freedoms and rights
the other party is not participating in
democracy they're tearing it to the
[ __ ] ground
the same justice who wants to make sure
that you don't have access to
contraception
is the same [ __ ] who tried to
overturn the election in 2020. that's
right i [ __ ] said it
that same [ __ ] him and his wife
trying to make sure that donald trump
remained an illegitimate president
impeach that [ __ ] now
right now get the evidence get it down
to the house get it to the house floor
and see that jenny thomas and clarence
thomas were in cahoots to overturn this
election and then to cover it up by not
allowing the january 6 select committee
to have the information that they need
for their investigation the only [ __ ]
vote against it the only one
throughout the day i can tell you though
the crowd is growing larger and larger
as perhaps news is finally starting to
reach people about this monumental
bombshell decision coming out of the
high court today if you're not pissed
off this morning i didn't even [ __ ]
do my hair look at this look at this i
didn't do my hair i'm so [ __ ] pissed
off
if you're not pissed off this morning
you're not doing it correctly
and again as we continue to learn more
about my daughter
now
has less rights
than my wife and my mother had
think about that for a second think
about it for a second
we are now taking that
away
right
away
from
have we went the opposite direction
and taking away people's freedoms are
taking away people's liberty
we've always progressed we've always
advanced even if ever so slightly
and it took a long time
and it seems like we've digressed
and we have in this country there's
history the show that we digressed after
the civil war in the south
[Music]
but people fought
and fought hard
and here we are here we are
after 50 years of proof that a woman's
choice of her health care between her
and her doctor
is safe back in the day when donald
trump was on twitter we probably would
have had an immediate reaction but he
will clearly i suspect take a lot of
they don't care about safety they don't
care about medical decisions they don't
even really care about abortion folks
you know that right this is not this is
not about abortion this has nothing to
do with abortion clarence thomas's
attack on contraception
and who you can and can't love it's not
is it has this has nothing to do with
abortion this has everything to do with
creating a fascist state to tell you
what you are going to do and they're
going to force you to [ __ ] do the
next step the next step believe you me
believe you [ __ ] me
the next step is to a national religion
they're already talking about it they're
already pushing it
and they want a national religion to
control you because they want to control
who you [ __ ] believe and what
information you you do and do not digest
they are not the party of freedom they
are not the party of liberty they are
the exact opposite
these are the same [ __ ] that
tried to overthrow our election
it's our [ __ ] election it we the
people are the government
and that's how we that's how we change
this us we we get out we put our [ __ ]
feets on the street and we participate
in the ballot
we do what democracies do best
that's what we do that's how we do it
we need 13 justices we got 13 appellate
court districts 13 justices only makes
sense we can do that
we
the people can do that
that's right
go vote
there's plenty of senate elections
there's house elections in every single
district go [ __ ] vote go engage in
the ballot
engage
register people talk to people
get in their ear about what what these
people want
it's not just about abortion they want a
fascist state
they want to take all your liberty away
especially liberty from people who don't
look like them
who don't aren't the same race as them
and i mean [ __ ] white people white
[ __ ] nationalists
they don't have the same religion as
them
they don't have the same views as them
the same ideas the same solutions
hell eric greitens in [ __ ] missouri
wants to kick down your door and kill
you
if you're a republican and you just not
quite trump enough
not quite fascist enough
but here we are
here we are
let me tell you something i'm gonna use
this microphone i'm gonna keep yelling
and screaming as long as you people will
listen i don't care if there's one of
you two of you are ten thousand or two
hundred thousand
i will keep yelling into this microphone
it's time we organize
it's time
we show these fascists who we are we
tried to show them in 2020 that there
was eight million more of us
and i believe there's more now i believe
people are waking up to the fact that
these [ __ ] fascists try to overthrow
our government they have overturned our
court they have taken control of our
court and they're taking away people's
rights
it's time that we practice democracy if
you claim to be pro-democracy practice
it
now's the time
that should be our national religion
for the next decade is democracy
democracy democracy democracy it's ours
only if we keep it
we keep it
if you truly believe in the words that
you're saying
go engage
there's plenty of ways to get engaged
and as the days and weeks take on here
to the midterm
we will help you because you know we are
proud partner of midas touch we air from
the midas touch facebook page every
single weekday monday through friday as
as well as youtube twitter and twitch
so stay engaged in those places
it's not just about tweeting it's not
just it's not just about sharing and
retweeting
you have to you have to get out and talk
to folks you have to engage in this
ballot if you have any any spare change
at all give to these these candidates
that can win these senate races
the filibuster stands in our way
we must
crack the filibuster it's enough
and we can't blame it on joe manchin
he's not running he's not running folks
that's not part of what we you can't
just say mansion mainstream mansion we
have to go where these elections are
this year right now the stuff that we
can control the things that we can
change right now we we have the power to
change these things we do
the people in ohio the people in florida
the people in missouri the people in
texas you have the ability to change
you do if there if there is a
election in your state
and there's elections in every
congressional district but if there's a
senate race now now is the time now
you can do this
you are the one who will make this
change
you are the one
and yeah i know they're going to say oh
both sides are the same no they're not
they are [ __ ] not the same if you
look at today's decision yesterday's
decision and today's decision and still
are on this [ __ ] delusional
slide that both parties are the same you
need to pluck your head out of your
[ __ ] ass they are not the same
i wish we had two pro-democracy parties
in this country i [ __ ] wish but we
don't
there is only one party that is for
democracy and i hope we can move towards
a direction where we do have two parties
that are for democracy so we don't have
to work so goddamn hard to fend off
fascism
but that's where we are at now
right now we have to fight back against
fascism
and it's coming for you and your family
i don't care if you're [ __ ] a
socialist or democratic socialist or a
liberal or a democrat or an independent
or a moderate or or a a conservative
liberal or or a or a socially liberal
conservative i don't give a [ __ ] they're
coming for you
they're coming for your way of life
they're coming for your [ __ ]
children's school they're coming for
your [ __ ] community they're coming
for your [ __ ] church they're coming
for you
next next is to tell you what religion
you have to be
trust me
thomas is already setting up telling you
who you can and can't love
who you can and can't [ __ ]
who you can and can't be in the
relationship when and when you can't
[ __ ]
they're already down that path they're
already these chris these christian
nationalists marjorie taylor green said
it
they want christian nationalism and they
want it now
and they're gonna do anything even try
to overturn an election
a free and fair election they'll try to
overturn by with eight million more
votes
an electoral college win that was as big
as trump's
when he lost by three million votes
popular
we see with the select committee that
they're willing to overturn that
election they were trying their
damnedest to steal our democracy
and today they're stealing our democracy
through the supreme court
yesterday they were they were against
states rights today they're for them
they're stealing our democracy away from
us folks and they're to continue they're
not going to stop stealing our democracy
they're not going to stop
it is only up to us the people out there
who can engage in the ballot that's what
you have to do and i'm not just talking
about marking your own ballot
you have to march you have to talk to
people if you can't physically march
call
find a campaign that you can call and
text for
you don't have to live in ohio to help
that senate candidate you do not have to
live in florida to help that senate
candidate you can't vote for him but you
sure as hell can [ __ ] help him now is
the time to get involved in your
democracy whatever your skill is
if your skill is yelling and screaming
in the streets go do it
if your skill is text messaging do it if
your skill is writing letters do it if
your skill is talking to people to get
them registered to vote because they're
[ __ ] pissed do it whatever your skill
is right now
use your skills use your skills to save
your democracy and engage in the ballot
now is the time
right now
don't stop don't relent don't don't
think that it's over this is not over
we have the ability and yes you're gonna
hear it this is the most important
election ever in your lifetime and as
soon as soon as the ballot closed and
the votes are counted in this election
the next election will be the most
important election of your lifetime
because they're not gonna stop
they're not going to stop
we're gonna cut to joe biden joe biden
is uh president biden's supposed to give
uh a statement on this decision
uh at the bottom of the hour in about 10
minutes uh you can see i have the the
video from c spanned up here that the
protest you can hear some of the
protesting going on in front of the
supreme court they put up the fences as
you can see the fences around the
supreme court
ahead of this as if as if peaceful
protesters are going to go in and
break down the doors and smear skin on
the walls these people are not there to
overturn this decision these people are
there to be heard in a peaceful protest
and to know that in november we will
come after you if you support this
decision to overturn roe v wade if you
are against americans having rights and
freedoms to their bodily autonomy or our
safety in in public away from [ __ ]
firearms
children being safe to learn in schools
if you're for people not being bankrupt
for if you're if you're for people being
bankrupt for health care we are going to
vote against you it is time to use our
vote like the republicans have always
used their vote for decades we must vote
against fascism everywhere we can
everywhere we can if you have a legal
ballot
go vote
it's time to use the weapon of the
ballot
to smash fascism
you can do it don't think you're just
one vote you can only vote once
but you can engage in the ballot
you can engage in in politicizing this
yeah oh third democrats are just gonna
politicize this issue they're gonna
politicize the january 6th select
committee they're going to politicize
gun control they're going to politicize
roe v wade you god damn right we are
you goddamn right we are we are going to
politicize anything and everything every
[ __ ] inch every [ __ ] millimeter
because our democracy depends on it
you goddamn right we're gonna politicize
this
hondo percento gonna politicize the
ever-loving [ __ ]
out of your fascism
jeffrey clark on tucker carlson's show
last night oh
oh
they're politicizing me trying to
overthrow the government of the united
states of course we are
of course we're going to politicize this
we're trying to save our democracy from
you [ __ ] buffoon ninga poop nazis
of course we're going to politicize it
don't let anyone shame you into
politicizing anything
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] him [ __ ] him [ __ ]
him politicize the [ __ ] out of every
[ __ ] inch
you want your children to be safe in
schools by god get out there and
politicize it like a [ __ ] like
their lives depend on it
if you want to make sure women have free
safe
abortions
and medical care
and choices for their bodies
politicize like your [ __ ] life
depends on it because it just [ __ ]
might
politicize every [ __ ] inch of this
don't back down
now is the time
you're not gonna hear me get all kinds
of cushy and elite on your ass
that said that's not what you get in
this content here at the tony michaels
podcast we don't do that [ __ ] coastal
elite liberal [ __ ] where we give you all
kinds of [ __ ] statistics and all
kinds of [ __ ] for you to sit and scour
over no you do not have time to scour
over [ __ ] statistics
you do not have time to get in an
argument with someone on twitter about
[ __ ] statistics
your life and other americans lives
depend on it right now
to politicize the [ __ ] out of this get
in the streets make phone calls find
your candidates
it's time
not not
tomorrow
not next week not a couple months from
now not election day now is the time to
beat back fascism
you use your voice
we still have a freedom of speech at
this point
we still have we still have the right to
vote at this point
we still have those things they're
trying to take them away folks
they're trying to [ __ ] take them away
don't let them take that [ __ ]
away
don't let him
use it or lose it
your freedom of speech and your right to
vote if you do not use it now if you do
not use it in this point in history if
you don't stand up against fascism
you will lose those rights they have
proven it today
they will strip you of those rights
and they will use fear
they will use threats and they will
definitely use their [ __ ] religion
no matter how bastardized the religion
that they're using is because frankly
i think jesus would have a few curse
words to say to these [ __ ]
today don't
you
putting women's lives at risk
it's not for this [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's a goddamn nuff
get engaged
be pro-democracy
but more than anything
participate in your democracy
stick around we will be right back
with words from joe biden
when he appears at the podium right
after these messages
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your pardon blanket
today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
see the scene here in front of the
supreme court
the springboard has made the decision to
overturn roe v
decision this morning we knew that they
were going to bring this decision
several weeks ago
in a draft league
way more worried about the leak of the
decision
than actually taking away your rights
away you see the scene here uh
developing in front of the supreme court
we've got the c-span feed up and we are
going to stay
uh live with this feed because i think
this is the feed where
uh the president joe biden will actually
be giving a statement on this decision i
want to bring in uh my co-host
and executive producer here uh gabe
sanchez gabe how are you
uh i've had better days yeah well i know
you're i know you're on the road and i
know you're broadcasting from a secret
bunker somewhere uh but um
we missed you yesterday gabe uh you know
i i i have to say
yesterday i outed you and said gabe has
vacation he i'm the only one running the
board and people took it as
that i was knocking on you
and i i want to say i want to say i want
to tell all the people out there that
that thought i was knocking on gabe
yesterday in the comments
i was not true
it is well yeah yeah well i do that i do
that you know otherwise sometimes on
camera sometimes off but but yesterday i
just wanted to make them know that if if
it seems glitchy it's not gabe's fault i
didn't want them to think you were
behind the scenes helping operate things
because that's not what was going on i
didn't want them i didn't want them to
say where's gabe at what the hell is
going on gabe geez can't you run the
microphone yeah yeah no no it's fine i
can't have my uh my reputation at risk
right you know people expect a certain
quality you know production from me and
if it begins to teeter the opposite way
then now i know that my scapegoat is
always tony if that's right
yes tony always blame it on me always
blame it on me my name is on the show so
it is probably my fault even if it
doesn't seem to be it probably is
anyways uh but no i i do want to say
thank you because even on the road
yesterday you were able to get all the
overlays all the art done that we needed
done all the production
components that we needed for the
hearing it went great yesterday and you
you actually joined us um from an
undisclosed location where you're
traveling somewhere it seems you know on
mars or something but yeah who knows who
knows where i was going but i will say
yeah i you know i was able to watch uh
uh the hearings from the plane and i
gotta say like
there you know i a true bombshell of uh
of
of witness testimony depositions you
might even say there was quite an
explosive one that happened
uh for why marjory taylor green
you know requested a pardon i don't know
i'm sure details the thing is like
the great thing about these hearings is
that they have presented
the public with information right and
now the public
is curious
to know more about those things like
before we heard whispers and it wasn't
confirmed or this or that they're kind
of through the rumor bill rumor mill
and now we're finding that these are on
the actual record they are stated with
evidence there are depositions people
under oath documents proving these
things
and now the public is like wait wait
what was that
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait what
was that you know it's what it is now
one of those things where
you're seeing you know involvement from
jenny thomas and in emails you know the
wife of clarence thomas the man which
ties back to the decision today when in
his decision he is invoking his his
religious bigotry on people about
contraception and who they can and
cannot love and who you can and cannot
marry and be in a relationship with
which is really funny coming from
clarence thomas being a black man in a
relationship with a white woman and i
believe that is everyone's right to love
who you want to love but he apparently
only thinks that right may be reserved
for special people like him i mean
exactly you look at the republican party
and it's always been that way it is you
know what is good for me not good for we
right like it is it is one of those
things the republican party says
i have access to these things i have
these rights but you don't whether it's
yesterday we're going gonna say as a
supreme court on a federal level tell
you how gun should be regulated in the
state of new york in terms of carry
uh open carry but today we're gonna say
oh actually you know what we're gonna
we're gonna let the states actually
decide those things and not have a say
into it right and then you look at
everything that the republican party has
done it's always you know two-sided flip
with the coin one day it's this the next
state's the complete opposite there are
hypocrites and they are there are people
who will project their own insecurities
whatever might be
um you know their own kind of what they
would rather be allowed to do on their
own but not allow everyone else to do
and we see it again and again and again
and today is just another example of
that you know i was at breakfast and i
was you know trying not to be the downer
because i was like oh i actually have to
go a little earlier than expected
to prepare for the show and they're like
oh why and i was like i actually have
uh intentionally not said anything but
it's because of roe v wade and they're
like oh [ __ ] and they knew and
my girlfriend and her sister both were
like
both of us like as women and all the
other women in california are under a
protective kind of coat right we've
we've we're lucky enough to live in the
state of california that actually
respects women's rights and their choice
but the thing that they brought up was
like can you imagine being a 16 year old
in one of these other states alabama
mississippi oklahoma like whatever it
might be and not having that choice
being told by some old white man
that says oh actually you know what
we're gonna decide what you can and
can't do with your body
and that's the republican party they'll
tell you what they want to do with your
body and your rights
and you don't have freedom under their
rule
because they're fascists
well i mean we've seen yesterday where
they think
states do not have rights states do not
have rights to regulate uh gun guns you
can just you can just [ __ ] everyone's
safety [ __ ] everyone's safety just let
anyone carry whatever whenever however
they want you can't you can the state
does not have the right to tell white
people that they can't carry guns right
that's that's what they're saying today
they're saying the state
definitely has the rights to tell women
what they can and can't do
this is clear what they're trying to do
this is very clear states rights only
works in their favor when they wanted to
only when they wanted to now states do
have rights folks that is a thing that
is inside our constitution states have
rights states have the right to regulate
things like i don't know say guns they
actually have the right to regulate
abortion which is [ __ ] vitally
important it's vitally important to
women's safety that states actually
make sure that licensed practitioners
are performing
the these medical procedures that that
it's done in a very safe way this is
very important that we do have oversight
over these medical procedures
but
you cannot you cannot take someone's
liberty away from that choice you have
to you have to make sure that that if
you make that choice like just i i mean
gabe you make the choice to drive a car
right you make that [ __ ] you don't have
to drive a car you live in l.a there's
probably plenty of public transportation
you could take advantage of or you could
ride a bike and i know you own the
skateboard
do you own a skateboard yeah i i do own
a skateboard you know well i just side
note i actually
today it might reveal where i am i
actually just ran into tony hawk on the
street
randomly are you serious and here we are
talking about skateboarding yeah 100 i
just saw him outside like a few hours
ago but here's but here's what i want to
here's where i'm going with this is that
you choose to drive a car but you don't
choose to drive a car and it'd be
completely unregulated right i mean you
can't just drive down the highway
crashing into things you can't you can't
legally drive without a suspended
license you probably have to pay to
license and insure your car there's all
and you know the car itself the car
itself has all kinds of regulations in
the state and the federal government to
make sure that people are safe
just the same way that they [ __ ]
negated yesterday that the state has the
right to make sure its citizens are safe
in its state by regulating firearms
but today is the exact opposite they
don't believe in regulating medical
procedures
safely for women what they believe is is
you don't have the liberty to make that
decision
i mean i completely forgot how much
actual work it took to get your license
like when
when all the shootings have happened
recently and obviously they've become a
very
uh you know top top of the surface kind
of conversation like everyone's
discussing it you know i had to go back
and i was like i you know was it like
how many hours did i actually have to
train or
get school on
on my permit you know how long did i
take to do the test and all these things
and i remember i was like i remember a
few things and i went back to look and
it's like 25 hours 50 hours like
whatever it might be in terms of there's
a couple different ways you could do it
but you've got to take the test you get
your permit you know you have to be you
get your driving hours
with someone who has their license i
mean i believe it's above the age of 18
or 21.
like these are things that
you have to do in order to get your
drivers i'm going to go i'm going to go
get a president here
it's a sad day for the court and for the
country
50 years ago
roe v wade
was decided it has been the law of the
land since then
this landmark case protected a woman's
right to choose
her right to make intensely personal
decisions with her doctor
free from the inner from the
interference of politics
to reaffirm basic principles of equality
that women have the power to control
their own destiny
and it reinforced a fundamental right of
privacy
the right of each of us to choose how to
live our lives
now with rogue on
let's be very clear
the health and life of women in this
nation
are now at risk
as chairman and ranking member of the
senate judiciary committee
as vice president now as president
united states
i've studied this case carefully
i've overseen more supreme court
confirmation than anyone today
where this case was always discussed
i believe roe v wade was the correct
decision as a matter of constitutional
law and application of the fundamental
right
to privacy and liberty and matters of
family and personal autonomy
it was a decision
on a complex matter
and drew a careful balance between a
woman's right to choose
earlier in her pregnancy and the state's
ability to regulate
later in her pregnancy
a decision with broad national consensus
the most americans of faith
and backgrounds found acceptable
that have been the law of the land for
most of the lifetime
of americans today
and it was a constitutional principle
upheld
by justice is appointed by democrat
and republican presidents alike
roe v wade was a 7-2 decision
written by a justice appointed by
republican president richard nixon
in the five decades that followed roe v
wade justice is appointed by republican
presidents from eisenhower
nixon reagan
george w bush
were among the justices who voted to
uphold the principles set forth of roe v
wade
it was three justices named by one
president
donald trump
were the core of today's decision to
upend the scales of justice and
eliminate a fundamental right for women
in this country
make no mistake
this decision is a culmination of a
deliberate effort over decades
to upset
the balance of our law
it's a realization of an extreme
ideology and a tragic error by the
supreme court in my view
the court has done what it has never
done before
expressly take away a constitutional
right
it is so fundamental
to so many americans that had already
been recognized
the court's decision to do so will have
real and immediate consequences
state laws banning abortion
are automatically taking effect today
jeopardizing the health of millions of
women
some without exceptions
so extreme that women could be punished
for protecting their health
so extreme that women and girls were
forced to bear their rapist
child
with a child a consequence
it just it just
stuns me
so extreme the doctors will be
criminalized for fulfilling their duty
to care
imagine having a
young woman having to
carry a child
of incest as a consequence of incest
no option
too often the case
the poor women are going to be hit the
hardest
it's cruel
in fact the court laid out
state laws criminalizing abortion
that go back to the 1800s
as rationale
the court literally
taking america back 150 years
this is a sad day for the country in my
view
but it doesn't mean the fight's over
let me be very clear and unambiguous
the only way we can secure a woman's
right to choose
the balance that existed
is for congress to restore the
protections of roe v wade as federal law
no executive action from the president
can do that
and if congress
as it appears
lacks the vote to vote to do that now
voters need to make their voices heard
this fall
must elect more senators representatives
who will codify
the woman's right to choose into federal
law once again
elect more state leaders to protect this
right at the local level
we need to restore the protections of
roe
as law of the land we need to elect
officials who will do that
this fall roe is on the ballot
personal freedoms are on the ballot
the right to privacy
liberty equality they're all on the
ballot
until then
i will do all of my power to protect a
woman's right in states where they will
face the consequences of today's
decision
well the course decision casts a dark
shadow over a large swath of the land
many states in this country still
recognize the woman's right to choose
so
if a woman lives in a state that
restricts abortion the supreme court's
decision does not prevent her from
traveling from her home state to the
state that allows it
does not prevent a doctor
in that state
and that state from treating her as the
attorney general has made clear women
must remain free to travel safely to
another state to seek care they need
my administration will defend that
bedrock
if any state or local official high or
low
tries to interfere with a woman's
exercise and her basic right to travel i
will do everything in my power
to fight that deeply un-american attack
my administration will also protect the
woman's access to medications
that are approved by the food and drug
administration the fda
like contraception
which is essential for preventative
health care
myth mifo prestone
which fda approved 20 years ago
to safely end early pregnancies
and is commonly used to treat
miscarriages
some states are saying that they'll try
to ban or severely restrict access to
these medications
but extremist governors and state
legislators are looking to block the
mail
or search the person's medicine cabinet
or control a woman's actions by tracking
data on her apps she uses are wrong and
extreme and out of touch
with the majority of americans
the american medical association
the american college of obstetricians
and
gynecologists wrote to me and vice
president harris stressing that these
laws are not based on are not based on
evidence and asking us to act to protect
access to care they say by limiting
access to these medicines
maternal mortality will climb in america
that's what they say
today i'm directing the department of
health and human services
to take steps
to ensure these critical medications are
available to the fullest extent possible
and the politicians cannot interfere
in the decisions that should be made
between a woman and her doctor
and my administration remain vigilant
as the implications of this decision
play out
i've warned about how this decision
risked the broader right to privacy for
everyone
that's because roe recognized the
fundamental right to privacy
that has served as a basis for so many
more rights that have come to take we've
come to take for granted
that are ingrained in the fabric of this
country
the right to make the best decisions for
your health
the right to use birth control a married
couple in the privacy of their bedroom
for god's sake
the right to marry the person you love
justice thomas said as much today he
explicitly called
to reconsider the right of marriage
equality
the right of couples to make their
choices on contraception
this extreme and dangerous path the
court is now taking us on
let me close the two points
first
i call on everyone no matter how deeply
they care about this decision
to keep all protests peaceful
peaceful peaceful peaceful no
intimidation
violence is never acceptable
threats
and tim and intimidation are not speech
we must stand against violence in any
form
regardless of your rationale
second
i know
so many of us are frustrated and
disillusioned that the court has taken
something away that's so fundamental
i know so many women are now going to
face incredibly difficult situations
i hear you
i support you
i stand with you
the consequences
and the consensus
of the american people
core principles of equality
liberty
dignity
and the stability of the rule of law
demand that roe should not have been
overturned
with this decision
the conservative majority of the supreme
court shows how extreme it is
how far removed they are from the
majority of this country
it made the united states an outlier
among developed nations in the world
but this decision
must not be the final word
my administration will use all of its
appropriate lawful powers
but congress must act
that with your vote
you can act
you can have the final word
this is not over thank you very much
more to say this in weeks to come thank
you
is the supreme court broken
finishing up with the president if you
missed any of what he had to say on the
supreme court decision remarks by
speaker pelosi or house minority leader
kevin mccarthy and a group of house
republicans today at the capitol we
showed you all of that we encourage you
to go
okay there you have it the uh
the statement from president joe biden
um on the
overturning of roe v wade from the
supreme court um a couple things that he
said gabe i i i
i want to go to a video here uh soon
that midas touch put together a while
back and everyone's like oh that's so
crazy that you're you're being
ridiculous and here the president united
states is basically pointing his fingers
at these fascists in these red states
and said you
do not don't try to restrict women's
right to travel right do not try to
restrict the mail do not be a fascist
and bust down their door eric greitens
and use your guns and your scary little
tactics to search through their medicine
cabinets do not try it we will use we
will use what we have to make sure that
the rights that are still remaining for
women inside the states where they are
now second-class citizens in some states
and you across an imaginary line and now
you're a citizen again
will remain to have those rights
because
yeah that's exactly what the president
of the united states was saying which is
absolutely it's 2022 and the president
united states has to warn
fascist governors and fascist state
legislators to make sure they know hey
people have the right to travel
[ __ ] people have the right to
the mail and you can't restrict it i
mean you know you you mentioned midas
touch and there's a video that you're
going to show and i know which one it is
but i mean the same is it
kind of under the same kind of token
there is when people are like oh you
know this like if i make a sketch or
something like that people are like oh
this is so crazy like it would never be
like this right and it's like you know
some of us were able to yourself
included able to read through the lines
of what they're doing right they are
pushing the envelope to an extent and
testing what is there and what they can
get away with and then each time they go
further and further and further where
reality is heightened to what is now 20
and every day you wake it up and say
like well you know for me like how can i
make a sketch that makes fun of this
well it's hard because each time you're
like this is so absurd this is so
unrealistic but really within a matter
of days or weeks or months it does
become reality we're right there we're
right there i mean i remember our
conversation we had a while back when
when these anti-vaxxers were drinking
piss
right and we were you were gonna make a
video and and i know it sounds trivial
and stupid right but you were gonna make
a video where they were drinking pee and
i'm like no you gotta you gotta have
them doing one step further because
they're already doing that right
they're already doing that and then we
find out days after you release that
thing they're eating dirt yeah they're
eating dirt which i mean dirt isn't [ __ ]
but i i mean we're not good enough right
but they were eating they were actually
eating toxic dirt at that
which
it's basically [ __ ] so so it doesn't
take long for them to get to where you
think they're gonna be and the reason
why it's so easy to predict what they do
because we don't actually have a magic
ball it's because they're fascist and
fascism
breeds
non-liberty and you know exactly where
that's headed like liberty gives people
choices right it allows you to be like
spontaneous it allows you to have
individualism right yeah fascism does
not allow you to have individualism it
does not allow you to be spontaneous it
does not allow you to live a lifestyle
that you choose with your freedom and
your rights and that's why they're so
easily predicted and that's why it just
gets easier and easier and easier to
predict them because they are fascist
right and they want it this is what they
want the ron desantis of the world this
is what they want the other the other
thing too is you just made me think of
is like fascists are unoriginal they are
not creative right they do not come up
with their own ideas what they do is
they go back and they reuse the same
playbook right they've been watching the
same reels of the games they've been
playing years and years ago
and instead of saying hey
maybe people will anticipate what we're
going to do we should change it up a bit
yeah you know no it's nothing
crazy because that's because they really
only have a simple set of core
principles and it's
only me that matters right and only only
someone who i
deem worthy that matters that's it
that's the core principle yeah i mean we
have marjorie taylor green
on her [ __ ] traitor tv show or
whatever podcast she's trying to do she
was talking about how christian
nationalism you shouldn't be scared of
christian national i'm like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah she's talking about don't be
scared of nazi germany right like that's
exactly what nazi germany was was
christian nationalism that's what hitler
used yeah and then and then yesterday
she at a podium and i i was hoping we
could play the video but we're probably
not going to have time because we got to
get the bonehead of the week we always
promised our viewers friday that we do
bowling of the week and we got a good
bonehead uh based on some of the
hearings that were yesterday but she she
starts to berate someone from from the
uk about
the facts that this that this
this journalist is telling her about the
uk and she's like go back to your
country and the only reason why margie
taylor green is so mad and she doesn't
want that person that room is because
that person is coming at her
with reality and logic right i mean her
response in that video when the person
in the uk is like well we don't have
mass shootings because we don't have
these guns that are right available and
she goes well you have knives and you
have mass uh mass uh stabbings right
which
which is insane if you look at the
numbers that's that's not actually the
case okay just like in any other
countries there are stabbings that
happen but mass stabbings is a
ridiculous concept to get around to be
like oh this one guy went and stabbed 30
people in a supermarket before somebody
could stop him that is [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then when she goes well you can just
go back to your own country if you don't
like it here
but that is that is the that is the
epitome of fascism that is exactly what
they want that is exactly what all of
these republicans say again and again
and again if you don't like it here then
you can go home somewhere else right you
don't if you don't want to be fascist if
you don't want to be fascist right then
don't be here because soon we will come
like eric greitens said and kick in your
door and we might just kill you i mean
yeah i mean if you're a rhino or anyone
who's against the mega party then bye
bye
we're coming for you right we're going
to kick in your door we're going to
shoot you we're going to go through your
medicine cabinet we're going to scroll
through your phone we're going to do
those things that that biden actually
brought up which i commend him for doing
because now just like liz cheney and
kindergarten and all these other people
on the committee brought up these things
as that's now on the record he has
brought it forward to be like don't be
surprised if they try to do this but we
will come after you if you try to do
these things because they're an invasion
of privacy they're an invasion of
someone's own home and what they do in
their own personal lives
well here we have the uh the midas touch
um the video that i was looking for
republicans have taken away your right
to choose
now take away their right to govern and
that's what you have the right to do
you have the right to go out and take
away their right to govern and the
hashtag is hashtag gop handmaid's tale
and the reason why that's the hashtag is
because that's the video that goes along
with it that mind is touch created here
and let me let me play this let me put
it up full screen get the branding off
here because i want i want everyone to
see this because
this is what joe biden's warning against
because he knows it's coming this is
what he's warning against right here
listen everything's gonna be okay right
just let me do the talking okay
good evening ladies
license please
where you headed oh we're just out for a
drive
headed to the border
oh no no we were just going up to the uh
hey there
what's your name
grace
are you pregnant grace
step out of the vehicle she does not
have to yeah she does
show me your hands on the wheels please
step out of the vehicle
[Music]
now when midas touch originally made
that video they got a lot of uh pushback
saying oh my god this is way too far
what are you guys crazy holy [ __ ] this
isn't you you guys are way out of whack
there's no way that this country's gonna
get to a situation where they would stop
women at a border to see if they were
pregnant or not yes they're going to
they're going to try insane
we're never going to do that it's like
all you need is to give them an inch and
they will take a mile on this well
they will come after you they will put
the cameras in they will spy on you they
will monitor you they'll attract you
they will do whatever they can they're
all right
they're already doing it and that's why
biden said it because they're already
trying to pass laws in these states to
prevent women and make them in the
felons that they cross a border to get
them to get a medical procedure they're
doing it here in missouri these fascists
here in missouri want to restrict women
from traveling to get a medical
procedure in illinois they want to
restrict it they're going to do it in
all these states and believe you me
they're they're not gonna stop
at just these states that want to pass
abortion restriction to where a woman a
woman does not have the right to choose
they're going to come after these blue
states
they're gonna do it folks they're not
gonna stop and go oh look roe v wade is
on the turn yay we can we can not fight
anymore we don't yeah right
yeah but we don't have to worry about it
anymore it's overturned so what we can
just now we did accomplish what we
wanted to accomplish because it was
never about roe v wade yeah it was never
about roe v wade it was never about
abortion they want to control you
they're [ __ ] fascist they want to
take your rights they want to take your
liberty away that's what they want that
is what they want
they will they will do whatever they can
you know when they were like oh it's
just abortion it's just abortion it's
just abortion like why you guys freaking
out it's like no it's not just abortion
because again they're going to use this
as precedent and that just like thomas
today he's going to say no well we
should maybe go after
contraception maybe go after same-sex
marriage like you know very interesting
that he hasn't touched on the
interracial marriage considering his
relationship but i wouldn't be surprised
if somebody decides to bring a case
forward and say you know what that
wasn't far enough
we need to now go after interracial
marriages i'd be very curious to see how
clarence thomas then decides to vote on
it because right now he's already like
it's not like other people are bringing
this up to the supreme court it's him as
a supreme court justice bringing up the
topic of contraception in same-sex
marriage it's like hey guys this
was cool but maybe there's more we could
do maybe there's more damage and
destruction and harm we can bring to the
american people and specifically women
but now other groups
i want to show you this here uh this is
the house floor right now like an agent
remember designated by mr turner of ohio
i informed the house that mr turner will
vote
for anyone uh wondering how government
works and why your choice matters
for who you vote for um here we have a
democratic house
taking up this gun violence legislation
that passed the senate with 14 votes
with 14 votes from republican i actually
i think it was 15 votes to be honest
with you uh it was 14 votes to bring it
to debate but now it's 15 votes to
passage but now it's going to the house
floor for amendments this is why it
matters folks if you think if you think
giving republicans would get this bare
minimum legislation and grant it
this is monumental in gun legislation
but it's kind of pathetic that this is
the monument that we have where it's
just bare minimum stuff
but that is it is something here and it
does show you why your vote is so
important it shows you why it is so
important for you to engage
because if you want to protect your
rights which they are protecting our
rights to safety here not from ourselves
but from people who want guns it's not
unreasonable to ask our government
ourselves to make sure that people who
have guns
have the best interest of that weapon it
is not out of step to ask that question
and this law does the bare minimum to do
that only the bare minimum but frankly
without having a democratic house here
gabe this what we're seeing on the
screen right now even the bare minimum
would not be happening right and yeah
and again it is the bare minimum like
there is so much more we could do but
they're like well i mean this will at
least appease people and make them okay
you know especially on the republican
side like you know going into november
the argument that could be made is like
well they didn't do anything it's like
oh no guys guys we voted we passed this
we did something now yeah we did the
bare minimum to make sure that we
weren't going to get voted out of office
now with roe v wade happening here i
think you know the republican party is
going to find out that they just voted
themselves out of the midterms in
november
because there is going to be a lot of
women a lot of young women a lot of
older women who who have to deal with
this right you know whether it's through
their family or who are uh will go
against the party to say well maybe they
don't have our best interest at heart
maybe they don't care about those right
maybe they didn't do enough to prevent
uh the government covering after my
uterus or the government you know
allowing uh these people to get a hold
of firearms to kill my children like
whatever it might be
i think the republican party is going to
now come to a uh a moment of regret
going as far as they are you know the
very few are controlling the majority of
this country and i think that's um you
know happening in november in the
midterms are going to reveal that at
least i hope
we have four minutes left in the voting
here um you see here on the screen that
um it looks like the democrats
are at 70 are the a votes are at 77 with
73 democrats for republicans 73 nay 74
nays
as it ticks up as they close voting in
four minutes it'll probably stay open
past the four minutes um
and we want we're not going to stay on
for that vote because that vote is just
for amendment that's just to bring the
floor because that's what a lot of
people don't understand they vote
several times on these bills right this
is just the opening vote but what i do
want to do uh gabe is i want to go to
bonehead of the week all of our audience
understands and knows that we do
bonehead of the week poll on twitter
every single week at toni michael's pod
you follow us there you can also
also find the poll on our youtube
channel so subscribe to our youtube
channel so you can participate in the
bone of the week poll every single week
um
yesterday we know we had the day five of
the senate um or excuse me the house
select committee's hearing of january 6
and boy was it a barn burner there was a
lot of new stuff that came out of that
and i think there's going to be a lot of
stuff come in july when they continue
these hearings and we'll cover every
single one of them over on the midas
touch youtube channel as we produce
those shows for everyone
but we had some special boneheads that
came out of oh man yeah there was a
whole list of them really i mean we had
a look i mean it wasn't until later that
night when it kind of we're like oh [ __ ]
we gotta figure out bonehead of the week
but also it's like we had to figure out
who was gonna bubble up to the surface
of these bigger kind of things i mean
even today
it wasn't until five minutes before the
show started when i changed who the
dishonorable mention was based on
everything that's happened so far and i
think people will agree with me on why i
chose this person but there were some
other there were some contenders for
just the race itself because i mean even
throughout the week but i mean we had
two hearings
and these were pretty revealing hearings
of people in the disgusting
boneheads that they are
well let's do this let's go to a break
and when we come back we will we will go
through your vote for bonehead of the
week
stick around don't go anywhere bonehead
of the week is up right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50 a day
you can help us help those true
americans recover from biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those trump
supporters and this is that moment send
your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
you know what time it is we're in the
second hour on friday on the tony
michael's podcast you know we air every
single weekday monday through friday on
youtube twitter and twitch
simulcast from the midas touch facebook
page but right now we are in the
bonehead of the week
of the week bonehead of the week boy do
we have a lot of boneheads to go through
so i don't want to waste any time in
case there's some more breaking news
that we have to cut out of bonehead gabe
so let's get to it
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to
this edition of bonehead of the week boy
do we have some boneheads um they start
to appear here um
yesterday the select uh hearing happened
so that's where our poll came from but
this morning there appeared some more
boneheads obviously yeah but everyone
voted on these three boneheads jeffrey
clark that name is starting to emerge
that america knows who that person is
now and what his role in trying to
overthrow our government and his role in
the cheeto dust kangaroo kuwas we also
have the cheeto dust mobster grandpa
poopy pants himself donald trump on this
on this pole and then drunk rudy grandpa
farty mcshardy giuliani now also on the
pole here i mean can you go back to that
photo let's just look at these three the
the three stooges right here is what i
was like you know it's just amazing
how well these people play together in
terms of trying to ruin the country you
know or at least attempting to ruin the
country it's insane what we what we what
we witnessed yesterday oh yeah i mean
even as the testimony came out even
during the fourth hearing right like we
talked about this after yesterday's
hearing but there's like if there was a
theme for the fourth one it was showing
how terrible a person donald trump is on
a human level as well as rudy giuliani
and the extent they would go to ruin
people's lives right you had the poll
workers and her and the public and her
mother they came up and they told their
story which was very very compelling and
very moving
and the fact that these people were like
oh yeah let me just ruin this person's
reputation everything they have in terms
of their livelihood and everything they
have going on in their life and claim
and and defame this person that they
were you know
cheating and doing drugs and doing this
doing that and then you find out
yesterday you're like oh hold on now
we're going to show how trump and
jeffrey clark tried to
hand they're individually tried to to uh
overturn the election and plan this coup
almost on their own
with these other people being like what
the [ __ ] is going on that that was some
of the most groundbreaking stuff
yesterday when they started to
because they were talking about the lead
up to january 6 right a lot like where
those components worked right who
jeffrey clark was like where he came
from but the thing that i was like holy
actual [ __ ] was when the the dudes that
sat in the meeting where donald trump is
trying to appoint
jeffrey clark to be the attorney general
so he can declare
that donald trump is the president
because that's
literally he just wanted someone anyone
to say that he was the president yeah
he's like can i get some sort of
confirmation bias here from anyone right
he was looking for the attorney general
then the vice president i mean this list
goes on and on oh there's the there's
the italian satellites that are changing
the records like exactly the absolute
[ __ ] i mean there's the there's the
quote that i am sure was going to live
forever which is you guys don't know how
the internet works basically where he
said like i don't think you guys know
how the internet works uh like the way
that i i yeah i i know how the internet
works better than you do or something
like that and it's crazy it's i mean
many many quotes have come out of this
thing rudy giuliani is saying like we
didn't have the evidence so we just
pursued it anyway right all of these
guys and you had they're given a
testimony you had donahue you had rosen
you had angle and they were both like
yeah we all came in on that day in
street [ __ ] clothes to handle this
meeting because trump was trying to tell
us how uh jeffrey clark who was a
subordinate was going to fire rosen
and then be his boss and and then i
think the funniest part of this and like
the [ __ ] goal that jeffrey clark has
is like yeah well i'll keep you on just
like for like special stuff if you want
to stay and rosen is like
[ __ ] no well rosen was like who the [ __ ]
are you right who the [ __ ] are you i
don't like you you are i know they were
like well because they've been brought
up they're like you don't actually have
any justification to be talking about
what you're talking about he's like well
i mean you know i've done this he's like
well you haven't actually
defended a case you haven't brought
anything on a on a on a high level
before and he's like well i've done some
environmental stuff and i think it was
donahue who said
you know in so many words said shut the
[ __ ] up and go back to your office and
when we have an oil spill we'll call you
right right that was incredible what the
thing the thing that was
that shows really who trump is
is when is when donahue is describing
that they between
donahue rosen and angle the three
witnesses yesterday in the room and they
basically said hey look
we've already contacted all the
department of justice there's going to
be mass [ __ ] resignations you're not
even going to have a department of
justice
for him to be the attorney general of
yeah
in the final 20 days of his presidency
right right well and when when they're
describing it to him trump finally
finally comes to his senses and realizes
that it will be worse for him if he
if he does this then better for him
right right he finally he finally has
some common sense talked into him at
that moment
and his first reaction when he says okay
i'm not going to make him the attorney
general meaning jeffrey clark he turns
to donahue
and he says now what are you going to do
about him and he points it down to you
and points at clark and says because he
at the in that moment
donald trump wants so bad for some
because he's a reality tv buffoon
he wants donahue to lean across the
table as if this is the apprentice and
go you're fired like literally or even
worse like he's imagining he's like if
he was a mob boss he's not gonna do the
hit he's gonna have someone else doing
it for him so he's like what are you
gonna do for me right but but donnie's
like well i'm not going to do anything
he's like why not he's like i can't do
anything he's a senate confirmed
department of justice official right i
can't do anything about him he's like
i'm also the deputy so i can't even
right below him right but that's the but
that's the thing is that it just
it just makes it more of the of what the
mindset of donald trump is that he does
not understand and even even up until
the final three weeks of his presidency
he still hadn't figured out that we the
people
choose a president the president gets to
nominate nominees for these offices and
we the people choose the senate and the
senate under our
our jurisdiction and our vote gets to
confirm those people to be a part of the
government he still
does not understand how democracy works
why we are democracy he really does
think the power of the presidency is a
dictatorship he really truly believes
that the office of the presidency is an
authoritarian figure he does not
understand it he's a [ __ ] idiot he
doesn't understand the actual power that
he had and that's probably why he's the
bone
on the bone end of the week right but
here you see the vote folks on twitter
the poll jeffrey clark got almost 50
percent
now gabe did this this same reflection
happened on youtube was it no it was
actually we've been getting this we've
been getting this a lot where the the
youtube first the first few times we ran
the poll on youtube and twitter we were
finding that they were pretty much in
line with each other and i almost just
had us i was like oh my god did i run
the poll wrong because i remember who
won and i was like wait is this who
actually did it and then in fact
the youtube outcome results
oh uh you know in ways overturned
what the results were on twitter and
flipped
because we we have two different states
here that we take votes from we take one
vote from twitter and one vote and we
count your votes
we are fair it is a free fair poll uh we
practice democracy here so you decide
who the bone in the week is and as you
can see here um
it looks as if jeffrey clark has one but
when you actually go to the count
someone else has one that appears
but first again like i saw that and i
was like oh shoot did i did i make the
video when that in the in the graphics
wrong and then i was like oh no okay
yeah this actually wasn't because when
you know i had to double check my i had
to do a recount on my own briefly a
recount well you know that's and that's
the other thing that was described
yesterday because we see one of these
[ __ ] boneheads rudy giuliani who was
really trying to pressure these
witnesses yesterday
as he was like the [ __ ] he was the
[ __ ] attorney for trump and all this
[ __ ] and rosen who is the acting
attorney general at that time because we
know bill barr resigned because he
didn't want to be complicit in federal
crimes rosen's like do not
do not have rudy giuliani contact me any
more i'm not talking to rudy [ __ ] rudy
rudy should not be anywhere near me i do
not want rudy anywhere near me or in the
department of justice because at one
point
they're trying to get mark rudy's trying
to get mark meadows to get rosen
to
um mess with this evident like these
schemes these conspiracy theories that
they have and he keeps trying to push
meadows the chief of staff tries to he's
trying to keep pushing this on the rosen
and he's using kind of rudy because he
wants rosen to meet with rudy because
rudy has this evidence
right and rosen's like look i am not i
don't want to [ __ ] see rudy i don't
even want to know it he exists at this
point if he's got evidence he's like go
to a [ __ ] fbi office there's 55 of
them go there give it to the agents in
the office it will work its way to me in
the appropriate form if there is actual
substance right to this claim
of voter fraud then somebody's gonna
bring it up and say hey yo you should
look at this but the fact that he then
responds like well i think it was trump
even right
but rudy was offended rudy was right
rudy was offended and then didn't he i
forget i in that moment was i was on a
plane was it trump or rudy that was like
well can he just like bring it to you
guys can't he just like write it to you
directly right exactly but and rosen's
like no that is not how it [ __ ] works
it doesn't work and you know what's
crazy about that
the actual thought because you got to
remember who rudy giuliani is rude
giuliani isn't just any shmo
this guy this guy was the united states
attorney
in the southern district of new york
like he was the bee's knees of federal
prosecutors in this country he ran
basically the department of justice 2.0
mm-hmm so he understands how evidence
works he understands how the fbi he was
in the department of justice he's not an
idiot he's been through the prototype
well
since leaving office as official mayor
and his
his role as uh uh you know southern
district like he has
definitely gone down in terms of uh
quality you know in both the hair dye
and his just sanity right and his
assumption that man you know what i just
gave you this stuff and you guys should
do it right like i'm rudy i'm rudy give
me it you know
but rudy giuliani
has become nothing other or nothing more
than
a drunken
harassing troll
that we definitely witnessed on during
the fourth hearing this week where he
was just spreading lies about people and
and trying to get what he wanted to do
like well we have tons of evidence and
they're like okay
show us the evidence
right raffensberger was like you got the
evidence you got the evidence like does
anyone have the [ __ ] evidence right
you're talking about um
rusty bowers like do you guys have the
evidence does anyone have the evidence
and they're like well well yeah we have
the evidence well we have theories but
we don't want to give it anything we
yeah so we don't we don't actually have
the evidence but we're gonna we're
working on theory right now and it's
like oh my [ __ ] god they're like you
guys gotta have something
at least like fabricate something give
me something that i can like go forward
with not just like well it's a bit of a
gut instinct
but i'm pretty sure joe biden cheated
it's like well if you don't have proof
then he didn't cheat right there's not
widespread voter fraud everyone else is
telling you guys that there's no
widespread voter fraud why don't you
listen the [ __ ] up
and realize the reality that's there but
again these guys are having a rager
that party is the is the united states
and they don't want to let it go they
don't want to they don't want to go go
go you know close down and we
we
we witnessed this yesterday as these
these three acting people well one of
them is not acting uh stephen engel was
in his official position right but
donahue and rosen were acting because
bill barr resigned so they had to step
up and be acting but even even the fact
that jeffrey clark
again was looking for any reason without
evidence it doesn't matter because he
was apparently doing his own
investigations in the [ __ ] that wasn't
real and there's a video
there's a video from um this character
um
eric hershman who is eric hershman keeps
[ __ ] breaking him
hilarious his justice bat but he's like
yeah i was there for everything
everything went through me he just has
no [ __ ] to give like he he does not
care and you can tell rosen's a no [ __ ]
kind of personality um but watch this
video where he's i think he's i think in
this video he's talking to clark and how
he's qualified for a job listen to this
and when he finished discussing what he
planned on doing
i said good
[ __ ] assuming sorry
congratulations you just admitted your
first step or actually take as attorney
general would be committing a felony and
violating rural sick city you're clearly
the right candidate for this job and
when we finish discussing what he
planned on doing
i said good
[ __ ] excuse me sorry
congratulations you just admitted your
first step in her act you take as
attorney general would be committing a
felony and violating rule 60.
it's crazy absolutely batshit crazy that
here is eric hirschman and you remember
he he's the one who told eastman go get
you a [ __ ] criminal attorney because
you're going to need it after january 6.
but this is when he's talking to clark
and clark's trying to convince him of
this nonsense that he wants to be
attorney general and hershman's like you
are a dumb son of a [ __ ] like you you
are the first thing you're going to do
as attorney general is commit a felony
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you like
it just
even people inside the trump circle were
aware that this is absolute batshit
crazy
and it just i mean you know i think some
of these people definitely had a case of
senioritis where they're like oh look
like i know you guys are kind of trying
to break the law here you know and
you're committing a felony and i'm just
gonna like give you a little warning if
you want to go about and do it good luck
we'll see what happens i don't really
care that much i got like three weeks
left in this administration so i'm just
trying to get out and go do something
else maybe in the private sector because
this shit's [ __ ] crazy right now i
just need to go
and i think that's the other thing too a
lot of people are like oh mike pence is
a hero
and he's like no mike pence is not a
[ __ ] hero okay he's a coward he's a
cuck he stood by and listened to
everyone talk about this stuff
as well as all these other people now i
am very glad they have come forward and
have given testimony but none of them
are heroes because they will in the same
breath turn around just like rusty
bowers and vote for [ __ ] trump if
he's the nominee right so i look at him
exactly so i look at this and i'm like
look
everyone here is guilty okay the sin of
omission
means that there is guilt now whether
that's a legal guilt or whatever you
know but i think there is a sin of
omission type guilt where all of these
people were aware of what people were
trying to do and were told not to do it
and they still watch these people try to
go forward with it and they didn't say
[ __ ] until the committee said hey
we need you to give a deposition and we
need to ask these questions and we need
to give you the we need to get the
answers to figure out what the [ __ ]
happened in these last couple months of
the administration
and so again all these people i'm super
grateful they came forward to reveal the
truth of what happened and you really sh
you really do see them say like man it
was [ __ ] crazy and i i warned them
but [ __ ] i was already like halfway out
the door when this [ __ ] was happening
and that's that's kind of where they
stood i mean that's why i say senior
writers on this it's like well yeah
talking but you know you didn't really
do well speaking of that because he
donald trump was looking for anyone to
be his jeffrey clark right anyone he
could to be his jeffrey clark
whether it was pence or jeffrey clark
himself or bill barr because here's the
scene here's a scene we have where liz
cheney is describing uh bill barr and
then we see a clip of bill barr talking
about the transition because the obvious
thing is why would the department of
justice do an investigation at all
because these are state the states run
the elections not the department of
justice so listen to this part this is
[ __ ] just a flame thrower and this is
bill barr again he's saying this behind
closed doors he wouldn't say this out in
front of publix again a [ __ ] counter
none of this stuff would come out when
he was doing a tour right but when he's
under oath and he knows he has the the
possibility of being
being convicted under perjury yeah then
he says the truth but listen to this the
former attorney general was asked why he
authorized the department of justice to
investigate fraud in the 2020 election
at all
why not just follow the regular course
of action and let the investigations
occur much later in time after january
6th
here's what he said
felt the responsible thing to do was to
be to be in a position uh to have a view
as to whether or not there was fraud and
frankly i think the fact that i put
myself in the position that i could say
that we had looked at this and didn't
think there was fraud
it was really important to moving things
forward uh and i i sort of shuddered to
think what the situation would have been
if the if the position of the department
was we're not even looking at this until
after biden's in office
i'm not sure we would have had a
transition at all
so there's bill barr saying we wouldn't
even had a transition like it wouldn't
and not forget about forget about
peaceful orderly at all we wouldn't even
had one he would have just declared
himself the king at
at that point i mean now
rather this fear of of bars was
justified or not you know i don't know
in that moment right because we're not
gonna know maybe until more evidence
comes out of what the conversation the
exact conversation between bar and trump
was because there's apparently three of
them that barr
is in his notes so those are the ones
that he keeps referring back to but here
he's talking about the investigation
that the doj ordered which is very
unusual in our democracy
that donald trump pressured him to have
right donald trump pressured him into
this into this investigation
so the question was why did you start
this investigation if
it wasn't if it wasn't necessary because
bill barr is saying if we would have
done it after it really would have
caused concern and we see that now with
a lot of people calling for
charges to be brought and
we see jeffrey clark himself our one of
our bonehead uh nominees here being
arrested in his pajamas on wednesday
and and and being searched at his house
and apparently they took his electronic
devices um is the word that's kind of
the news that is coming down i i will
say there is a uh
there are the hearings that are
happening
after july 12th which are gonna like
present national archive stuff so right
probably the things that he took
from uh
the uh the white house down to
mar-a-lago so expect a video for that
coming in july
but now that jeffrey clark's house has
been [ __ ] raided
and he had all these devices taken and
you know i'm just going to have to
assume certain things were discovered in
his home so probably expect a video for
that sometime soon well i would imagine
too
i would imagine too that
besides the secret videos that you
apparently have access to here of the
inside searching of jeffrey clark's
house i would imagine that the the the
federal the federal government has
cause
to to know what is on some of those
electronic devices and they have a
suspicion of what is on those electronic
devices um speaking of electronic
devices um our alpha cuck here appeared
in the hearing as well
matt gatz
uh you know oh they made a fool out of
him
um when
when the evidence starts to come out
that
people were seeking pardons
gabe you have this great video called a
pardon blanket and we played it earlier
in a commercial break i just wanna
i looked up today because somebody
messaged me and they're like oh man you
you know uh you were very spot on for
this commercial
and i and i looked back on the tick tock
to see when it was posted it was october
26
2021
and that was when
there was mention of some of these
pardons again
nothing had been confirmed these were
all in the rumor mill but there were
people saying like oh
gates had asked for a blanket pardon and
people like what the [ __ ] that's crazy
and this is about six months after the
whole like hey there's these sex
trafficking charges that are happening
with greenberg and him
but nothing had really come to the
surface of like actual
uh evidence for the public
and then there were
whispers of saying like oh yeah these
other people
question mark over who those people were
so i just threw a bunch of names in the
mix why i mean ones that make sense
right right right so
the alpha cucks that there are in
congress and and and bam you were almost
spot on but here's here's uh here's the
actual the the actual evidence that we
have um the on the official record from
the january six here's adam kindlinger
and this video is about four minutes
long but it plays through this thing so
let me let me pull uh some of this uh
this down here and i want to make this
big because this is some bombshell [ __ ]
game
right here about the
about the apartment so let's watch this
video and then we'll comment about the
boneheads particularly the alpha cuck
met gatz on the other side five days
after the attack on the capitol
representative mo brooks sent the email
on the screen now
as you see he emailed the white house
quote pursuant to a request from matt
gates requesting a pardon for
representative gates himself and unnamed
others
witnesses told the select committee that
the president considered offering
pardons to a wide range of individuals
connected to the president
let's listen to some of that testimony
and
with representative gates requesting a
pardon
believe so
the
general tone was
we may get prosecuted because we were
defensive of you know the president's
positions on these things
a pardon
that he was discussing requesting was
as broad as you could describe from
beginning it i remember he's from the
beginning of time up until today
for eddie and all things
i mentioned nixon and i said nixon's
pardon was never nearly that broad
and
are you aware of any members of congress
mr gates
and mr brooks
i know
both advocated for
there'd be a blind departed for members
involved in that meeting and a handful
of other members that weren't at the
december 21st meeting
um
as the preemptive part is
uh mr gates was personally pushing for a
pardon
and he was doing so since early december
i'm not sure why
she could reach out to me
to ask if he could have a meeting with
[Music]
um
mr jordan talks about congressional
parties that he never asked me for one
there's more for an update on whether
the white house is going to park members
of congress
mr gomer asked for one as well
and he has some harry potter too i'm
sorry
did he start talking
yes he did
did um
are you aware of any
conversations or communications
regarding the possibility of giving
congressman matt gates a pardon
um i know he had asked for it but i
don't know if he ever received one or
what happened with it
how do you know that congressman gates
asked for a pardon he told me
uh tell us about that
he told me it asked meadows for a pardon
were you involved in or did you witness
any conversations about the possibility
of a blanket pardon for everyone
involved in january 6th
uh i had heard that mentioned
yeah
do you know whether the president had
any conversations about potentially
pardoning any uh
family members
um
i know he had hinted at a blanket pardon
for the january 6th thing for anybody
but i think he had for all the staff and
everyone involved not with january 6 but
just before he left office i know he had
talked about that
the only reason i know to ask for a
pardon
is because you think you've committed
a crime
uh he's not wrong when does an innocent
when does an innocent person go um
i should probably get
a blanket part in here
for something i did wrong but i don't
know what i did wrong but i'm innocent i
just need to cover my bases why i think
it's very telling that more than one
person says that matt gatz was looking
for a blanket pardon because i think
that's really important when you look at
all the federal crimes that he's being
investigated for it was almost like matt
gatz was like you know what let's try to
overturn the government i'll get the
president to think that we've committed
crimes and then he'll give me a blanket
pardon which will who doesn't matter who
wins then i can use that pocket pardon
to then
make sure that i am i am released when
they come out and the joe greenberg case
drops and they accuse me of sex
trafficking now this goes to the
question are their pocket pardons right
that's what that's a good question
that's what the question is are
their pocket pardons i think that's the
thing that that maybe some of these
federal prosecutors are really being
cautious about so
and well here's what i mean by that
because a lot of people ask on twitter
why is it matt getz uh why isn't he
indicted yet and why isn't why isn't
this person indicted why isn't that
person indicted if you look at really
some of the people
who are involved in this and this list
of uh pocket pardons that is starting to
develop
it really does appear
that
the reason why department of justice is
acting
in a way that is very cautious and they
want to build a case
is because these people may have pocket
pardons they may have pardons that no
one else knows about besides donald
trump and them that was happened in
private they did it you know he wrote it
on a [ __ ] napkin or some [ __ ] from
mar-a-lago he's like this will do but
but we don't know if it will like and
the department of justice and these
prosecutors have no clue if that will be
validated through the courts so they
have to really make sure that they have
all their [ __ ] eyes dotted and their
t's crossed here and it's gonna take a
long time i think that's why it's taken
a long time for them to get to jeffrey
clark's house
i mean like you know
also there's this i i even tweeted this
yesterday but like the the
and i was you know joking but i imagine
this is probably how it went down is
like matt gates was like look i i need a
blanket party the white house is like
for what and he's like everything just
[ __ ] everything right everything from
the beginning of time up until today for
any and all things and they're like
what why why would you need that
right right because of your defensive
and president's position and he's like
yeah let let's go with that you know and
they're like the [ __ ] you know and
meanwhile he's like i just got to
protect myself from the sex trafficking
it just it's insane to think that these
people who are like guys i'm innocent i
didn't do anything wrong these are all
baseless claims uh i'm totally cool and
you should totally vote for me back to
like back into office uh i didn't do
anything wrong but in the event that you
guys ever think i did something wrong i
kind of need to keep this one in my back
pocket in case a rainy day comes along
and somebody tries to search my [ __ ]
house and i pull out this get out of
jail free card right and say actually
guys
[ __ ] you can't do [ __ ] so that's why
it's so big that we have this um
this georgia state case
right investigation that's going against
trump because obviously
that's right right so you know then
that's where they're hoping he'll try
though don't you yeah yeah yeah yeah
he'll try to totally even though he
knows that's not how it
works yeah
yeah it's it's it's insane so
uh
and here's the thing here's the thing
here's the craziest part there's people
gonna go to the polls in november and
vote for this [ __ ] oh yeah oh my
god how [ __ ] gross
the other thing the other thing that i i
it is disgusting but the special uh
assistant uh to the president um
hutchinson right i think is her name yes
yes yes the one that's sitting on the
couch right right yeah i think she's the
one that is gonna break this whole
[ __ ] thing apart i think she's like
sitting on a couch she's like look i
made it i made it a chore yeah she's
like oh yeah
and scott perry yeah [ __ ] that but i
like that when she starts like one they
already know
because like she didn't even bring up
marjory taylor green they're like and
did marjorie taylor green ever ask you
for one which is like wait where did you
guys get that from like why are you guys
asking about her clearly
they clearly they know and you know she
was a congressperson for like three
[ __ ] days yeah january 3rd 2021 is
when she came into office so here we are
we have hudginson who's the the the
special assistant to the the president
so she's this middle person that's
getting all sorts of communication
coming through to you know meetings and
get this communication may get this
message whatever
and she's like uh they were like oh did
matt gates ever come out he's like yeah
like since like december many times i
don't know what for
like he just wanted the pardon and then
he's like she he kept he kept asking me
about the pardon
i don't know what he wanted it for you
know it's like we all know what he
wanted for but she's like i don't know
he just kept asking for it right like on
multiple occasions any of jim jordan
who's like just want an update can can a
homie get an update on this i just want
to know what's going on congratulations
right right
and and and she doesn't actually say he
was requesting one but he wanted to know
about him yeah so they knew they knew
that he was going to get a gauge on how
we're all feeling about this again
pardons we're not getting pardons right
not asking for myself necessarily just
want to get an overall sense
if we just do i want to observe crimes
and not report it i'm jim jordan and i
don't report crimes when i observe them
i just want to observe them because i'm
which also
they're asking exactly what i mean based
on her account that she's telling right
now jim jordan coming in asking for an
update
kind of falls in line with the whole
fact that he's not able to remember any
point in time and or when he spoke to
donald trump on january 6. can't recall
i imagine
that information is going to come out
soon enough because like i said in the
beginning of the show like dear the
questions have been prompted the the
topics have been brought up by the
committee
about these events
we they're not going to reveal the story
not until the very end potentially where
we get to the third act and we're like
just when you thought
[ __ ] was going nuts oh what's really
going to hit the fan and so now people
are inquisitive they're going to ask
questions journalists investigators are
going to look into this they're going to
poke around try to find out
they're giving the public
the the the crumbs you know like the
little sample for them to say oh you
know what this was delicious
i need a full meal on this bad boy i
need to buy it well here's here's part
of that delicious crumbs that we're
gonna get from that documentary because
you know you know that jared kushner the
testimony that we've seen from afar all
he can talk about is uh what was that
word it starts with a p pardons like he
literally is like all i was working on
was pardons i mean jesus christ we had
to pardon 140 members of the republican
party in the congress i wouldn't be
surprised and you shouldn't be surprised
that jared kushner was out there
reeling and dealing taking prices for
what people willing to pay for these
parties well and and we see
that what they were saying in testimony
is different than what they were saying
in the moment because we're going to get
this documentary footage which is
i think it's going to crack this [ __ ]
wide open because there's a moment out
there with mike pence and i'm not going
to play it today but mike pence when he
receives some kind of notification about
the 25th amendment he's like ooh what's
this yeah he was like oh yeah
print me out a hard copy for the ride
home right i want to i want to read this
on a sheet of paper please but here is
here uh brett put this uh video together
with midas touch
of ivanka under oath and when she's not
under oath in the documentary footage
let's let's watch this to see how
[ __ ] disgusting these people are
it affected my perspective um i respect
attorney general barr
um
so i
accepted what he said was saying as the
president has said
every single vote needs to be counted
and needs to be heard and he campaigned
for
the voiceless and i think a lot of
americans feel very very disenfranchised
right now
and
really question the sanctity of our
elections
and uh and that's not right it's not
acceptable and
um
he has to take on this fight and he
wants to make sure that that their voice
is is heard um and and muted and will
continue to fight um
until every legal remedy is exhausted
and and that's what he should do
that seems a little that those two
statements seem to be to contradict each
other i mean i'm gonna go with the fact
that these people
you know they love their ego they love
their image they are the trumps right
you know ivanka takes on that uh theron
oh cnn ceo kind of vibe where she like
deepens her voice and kind of needs to
speak like this with people respect me
no one respects you regardless of your
voice level and how your pitch is nobody
respects you not even the [ __ ] g20
summit people so
you look at this documentary and she's
there
trying to give this idea that the trumps
are great and we're giving a a voice to
the voiceless whatever the [ __ ] that
means
and
in this documentary they're clearly
taking this as an opportunity to create
an image of themselves right because
they're like oh a camera wants to come
in and say and i'm sure alex holder was
like look we want to make a documentary
about you guys now alex holder is the
filmmaker right right filmmaker and i
wanna and i wanna imagine what he was
saying was he came in and was like hey
we wanna make a documentary about you
guys about this successful great
magnificent four years as president
we want to bring the american people
inside
inside the white house of the great
american donald trump and they were like
you have me at great yeah and they're
like great awesome donald trump great
again like this exactly like that was
right that's probably all you had to say
is like oh look like what's your pitch
yeah and he's like donald trump
and they're like you said great
come on in let's do that and they set it
up and everyone agreed to it and i mean
it's the same reason like you know you
some people might have ulterior motives
for why they make documentaries but you
also might realize halfway through the
documentary that that's not the real
story in which you originally come into
but i'm sure alex holder already knew
what he was planning on doing he wanted
them to open up talk about everything
every [ __ ] thing that they would
mention because he was like i only got
so much time left and this [ __ ] house
is burning down to the [ __ ] ground
and i just want to get the footage of
them inside running around trying to
hide the fact that it is burning down
and speaking of footage we've seen is is
amazing so far well speaking of alex
holder because it goes right at uh one
of the bonehead of the weeks that we
have here because i actually think it
displays
uh how when you when you elect someone
who is a reality tv star
how we get reality tv government and
reality tv reality like it's just
absolutely [ __ ] bone ended [ __ ]
which brings us to the actual uh um bone
end of the week i i'm gonna have to go
back to the dm and i want to do that but
it brings us to the bone of the week
donald trump because i want to get to
this alex holder thing but let's give
donald trump is due here
[Applause]
[Music]
so your vote for donald trump for
bonehead of the week now it's changed
because and i'm leaving the dishonorable
mention because of what has happened
today and we're going to go to the
dishonorable mention after the winner
because i believe if they would have
voted this morning they would have voted
for the dishonorable mention gabe i
really want to 100 100 but i want but i
want to show you this alex holder uh
he's actually on twitter here's alex
holder's twitter um i'm not following
him yet but i'm going to right now just
oh
they're here
um but here is um a statement that he's
giving for his subpoena for congress and
i'm not going to read through it but he
basically says yeah i'm going to i'm
going to give my footage my raw footage
and i think no this came out before the
hearing
on tuesday right
i i believe so now he's put it on his um
his twitter page but it it request it's
requesting the footage
from the interviews because to be clear
these are interviews that he was he was
conducting in a three-part documentary
series
about trump and his family in this
presidency right but there's the
statement there but this is uh here is
um
a tweet of some footage of donald trump
our winner and it said alex
says tweets himself he says it himself
the trumps did not have editorial
control full stop and the reason why
which proves my theory on he went in
knowing full well what he wanted to
[ __ ] do with this
and got them to be like oh yeah this is
great every every moment i'm sure that
despite his own like internal struggle
alex holder was like [ __ ] okay yeah
you're such a great person you're
amazing oh yeah you look great the tie's
a great color on you the complexion is
awesome you look amazing like just the
[ __ ] fluff that he has to give
to make sure that he gets the footage he
wants and it [ __ ] worked
but here's here's a bit of a why how
he's proving because this is the reality
star president more worried
more worried in this moment about how he
looks in this chair and how the table
looks than our democracy itself wants
this [ __ ] weird footage and it just
proves that
this guy
didn't
can release anything he wants from this
footage
and it's beautiful how he frames it up
here
you see [ __ ] sit down there okay
yeah mm-hmm
beautiful and you look you see him
looking up here right yeah he's looking
he's looking at the relay monitor that's
coming back right because because what
what he's looking at there's a tv that
is showing what the camera's showing
right because he and he's looking at his
shot now watch what he does about this
table here now we played this yesterday
and i used it as proof of what donald
trump he tries to get people to do
things you know to try to make him try
to make him feel but but watch this
because he really gets upset about this
table
but this is just proof in this moment
because this is the thing that donald
trump doesn't want you to see that he's
a phony and a fraud that it's all
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's all faked up he
doesn't want you to see that that alex
holder's saying no this is proof that i
i can release whatever i want of this
footage oh
oh
oh i don't think i won't have the water
in the picture yeah no no you can take
it off
you definitely don't want to appear to
not be able to drink water there sir oh
my god
you know you know what's hilarious about
the drinking water thing and now that
we're on the water glass
everyone thinks it's because he has some
kind of cognitive disorder it's because
he wears so much makeup yeah he wears
and he doesn't he doesn't want it to
dribble down his face he won't do a
straw
right because that look it makes you
look like like he called mike pence a
[ __ ] it means you know he thinks it
makes you look weak so so he he makes
himself look even more weak because he
doesn't want the the makeup dribbles
down but it's also like oh and it's just
you know the relation of like going
right you know close to it which is like
oh it looks kind of looks something like
kind of like he's a wimp well you know
it makes him look like a cuck but watch
watch what he does at the table here and
and then and then we'll go to the
dishonorable mention because i want to
get to her because today's news i want
to get to her
kind of table as well
yeah i must will take the table
[Laughter]
[Music]
put the table back and put the water on
the table without the thing on top of it
[Music]
so the thing on top is like a it's like
a coaster it's it's a it's a glass cover
right and then and then there's the
napkin underneath it and he didn't like
the look of the napkin in in the glass
cover yeah for the water but look at him
looking down like ooh what am i gonna do
if my water is not here for me it also i
mean like i will agree it does look a
little weird like there it looks like
there's a large open space now he has
nothing in him for like kind of
perspective so
i agree that the
i mean at least do you agree with you
agree with trump i agree with the
placement there but the idea that he's
like yes no okay the thing though is
he's so worried he is so worried
about that table more concerned about
that table than the rights of people and
the rights than democracy itself he
fundamentally does not understand that
the office that he hold that he held
what the power of it was and truly truly
that it was our office he just had the
privilege of presiding in it he truly
does not understand that he does not
someone else
who does not understand democracy i
believe
is susan collins she's our dishonorable
mention i'm leaving her for last because
of the decision that happened today gabe
tell us why you because you did this at
the very last moment yeah and it's
important to the decision that was made
by scotus i i some people i just quick
note some people were asking about alex
holder's uh twitter handle i just put it
in the chat so you can follow him there
on twitter uh i'm sure he'll he'll drop
more little snippets um and we'll get
more details as the hearings continue
but the reason as i'm sure everyone can
imagine why i put susan collins on the
[ __ ] dishonorable mention
is because of her clutching my pearls
and
they promised me as
as candidates or or nominees uh uh
gorsuch and kavanaugh and and uh barrett
they all promised me they would not
overturn roe v wade and they said it was
law of the land and they guaranteed me
that they would not do anything to
disrupt because that is so important to
me when everyone else is like dude do
you not notice they're [ __ ] crossing
their fingers behind their back right
now they're literally lying to your face
so that they can get them they can get
your vote
to become the next supreme court justice
and what
happens the leak comes you know not too
long ago
we find out that this is a potential of
being passed
and that today it does get overturned
and roe v wade is now you know it's its
future is now uh at risk or you know uh
for at least on the state rights level
and susan collins now is saying
oh maybe i should well she hasn't said
anything yet but i'm sure she's like oh
yeah well she'll be majorly concerned oh
yeah very very concerned
listen folks elections do have
consequences they and and it is no
it is no more displayed than this week
with the hearings that we have and the
decisions that are coming down from the
supreme court one that we're missing
highly is the separation between church
and state and the another one that is
that is totally not getting any uh
notice notice which is concerning is
about miranda rights and it just it just
speaks to elections have consequences
and what i mean by that is you have to
select your consequences because good or
bad they have consequences and the
consequences of the 2016 election for
people not engaging in that election was
to make sure that donald trump and the
fascists had the ability to try to take
over as much government as they possibly
could and we are we are now seeing the
ramifications of that this week
but in 2020 the elections had
consequences and the consequences of
that are playing out today as well on
the same stage where 15 republicans were
forced to vote for bare minimum bare
minimum gun safety regulations and now
the house is doing that again today
which will hopefully they'll take a vote
on the floor it'll get to the
president's desk and these regulations
can go into law but people
elections have consequences and every
single one of them this is the most
important election the one in front of
you because it has consequences and here
is why listen to what susan collins says
about brett kavanaugh i do not believe
that brett kavanaugh will overturn
presidents are overturned he noted that
roe had been reaffirmed 19 years later
by planned parenthood versus casey
and that it was precedent on president
he said it should be extremely rare that
it be overturned and it should be an
example you have obviously full
confidence
i do we talked about whether he
considered road to be settled law
he said that he agreed with what justice
roberts said at his nomination hearing
in which he said that it was settled law
i
could not vote for a judge who had
demonstrated hostility to roe v wade
because
it would indicate a lack of respect for
president
what judge kavanaugh told me and he's
the first supreme court nominee that
i've interviewed out of six who has told
me this is that he views precedent not
just as a legal doctrine but is rooted
in our constitution and he reveres our
constitution i asked him is it
sufficient if five current sitting
justices believe that roe should be
overturned and he said no
i would not support a nominee who
demonstrated hostility to roe v wade
because that would mean to me that their
judicial
philosophy did not include a respect for
established decisions judge kavanaugh
is the first supreme court nominee
to express the view
that precedent
is not merely a practice and tradition
but rooted in article three
of our constitution itself i will vote
to confirm
judge kavanaugh
so there you have it judge kavanaugh is
a [ __ ] liar and susan collins is a
[ __ ] bonehead thank you gabe
for the dishonorable mention because it
shows uh with susan collins standing
there at the very end lying lying either
lying to herself or lying to the senate
uh on official record that brett
kavanaugh was going to do something that
he wasn't going to do and she knew he
wasn't gonna do it that elections have
consequences and the reason why i say
election have consequences folks is
because you have to engage we have to
engage with the ballot it is up to us
this decision today from the supreme
court to overturn roe v wade is just not
a front to a woman's uterus it is a
front to your daughters your sisters
your grandmothers and they're coming
after you they're not going to stop in
the red states they're going to continue
with the blue states are going to
continue to to
to
at every single turn take away your
rights
jesus christ thomas says in the decision
gay marriage gay relationships same-sex
relationships even the contraception
they want to take away your right to
contraception on a federal level these
people are not going to stop that is
their mission that is their goal that
was the whole point of the whole goddamn
thing so elections have consequences
folks and right now there's only one
party only one that is interested in
democracy and you must vote accordingly
and you must engage in the ballot
accordingly otherwise we get more
[ __ ] boneheads like this dumbass yep
like the dishonorable mention that we
have today we get more boneheads like
this
making decisions for us on our behalf so
you must go vote do not let the
boneheads take over but for now for now
gabe that's the bone end of the week
stick around everybody we got a few
announcements right after the music
[Music]
[Applause]
oh bone end of the week i think that's
probably one of our
most that's my favorite segment oh yeah
it's a good it's a nice kind of
cathartic release where it's like let's
just go after these [ __ ] in the
list and i love that the audience gets
to decide right they get to decide and
there's two places you can decide you
gotta go to twitter you gotta file at
tony michael's pod and you can vote
every single week for bonehead of the
week you can also go to our youtube
channel the tony michaels podcast
searching on youtube don't forget to
subscribe there because you can vote on
youtube now for bone end of the week and
don't forget to download the stupid
thing the stupid little segment that we
do
gabe we cut that out and we actually
upload it on spotify apple google all
your favorite directories on sunday
because here at the donnie michaels
podcast we broadcast live every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch and we simulcast
from the midas such facebook page but
gabe we we actually publish an episode
every single day of the week every day
the directories because tomorrow will be
the best of the week and i think i'm
going to pull more of some hearing stuff
that we had because the hearings was the
best stuff that we had i mean yeah
it was great you know great stuff can't
i could not argue with you about that at
all like i totally agree
the stuff that came out of those
hearings i would say is the most
important outside of what happened today
those are the most important things that
we should be we should be finding out
and to get it out again and again and
again in helping to spread that message
and
and help the committee kind of
share what's going on i think is
incredibly important right now right
well i tell you what i i think all the
people that are going to be in the
streets protesting uh scotus overturning
roe v wade and susan collins
capitulating to people like brett
kavanaugh's lies i think those same
people the people who believe
believe that the january 6 select
committee is legitimate they believe in
the evidence that is being presented
because it is the facts it is the facts
and i believe that they will act on that
in this election the most important
election for pro-democracy people out
there if you're a fascist this election
ah man this
you hope everyone sits out in this
election but if you are for if you are
for democracy and you're pro-democracy
this is the most important one and and
this week has shown us that elections
have consequences so you must
you must go vote you have to engage in
the ballot
so make plans this weekend to start
doing it start engaging in that ballot
however your talents present to you
rather you can text email
make phone calls call engage go door
knock there's so many things that you
can do don't let anyone make you believe
that your voice cannot be heard because
it can it can be heard and let your
voice be heard just like we let our
voices be heard here because every
single weekday we will continue to yell
and scream into this microphone noon
eastern
11 central nine pacific monday through
friday for two hours youtube twitter
twitch and the midas touch facebook page
gabe until monday
until monday surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking